- This video is brought to you by Babbel.
(upbeat music)
What's up, guys,
Michael here to talk about the thing
that makes America truly exceptional.
No, not butter statues of Jesus,
although that is magnificent
and Garrett earned his win.
Today, we're talking
gun violence in America.
I know, it's heavy.
Americans are 25.2 times more
likely to be murdered by guns
than people in the top 22
wealthiest nations on earth.
And in 2020, death by firearm search 30%
among American kids and adolescents,
dethroning motor vehicle crashes
as their most common cause of death.
And if you're less of a human life
and more of a numbers person,
gun violence costs America an
average of $280 billion a year
in medical bills and lost productivity.
Also, it's really dark
that it's someone's job
to figure out how much productivity
is lost to gun violence.
And yet, an alien coolly
observing American pop culture
or American politics
could reasonably conclude
that guns rule.
That's because despite
the carnage they inflict,
a sizable portion of America
continues to really, really love them.
They occupy a special protected place
in our cultural psyche,
which makes just about any conversation
about policy surrounding it
super polite and totally civilized.
No, not at all,
it's like little kids arguing
about toys except their guns
that can kill people.
But let's put our big boy pants on
and take a deep dive into
America's gun violence problem,
where it comes from and what
it says about us as a nation.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Deep Dive.
Was America's gun violence inevitable?
But before we get into it,
I want to talk about this
video sponsor Babbel.
It's summer, and to me,
summer means vacation.
And part of the fun of visiting new places
is learning a new language
to help you fit in like a local
or at least as a well intentioned visitor
who's trying their best.
And Babbel is a language learning app
that can help you build
your language skills faster
than you can say bon voyage.
One of the things that's
so great about Babbel
is its focus on practical conversations
you'd have in the real world,
like asking for directions,
ordering in restaurants
and arguing about who's
the more powerful bald man,
Bruce Willis or Vin Diesel,
and the lessons are
designed by actual humans,
not algorithms, which adds another layer
of actual usefulness to
each 10 minute lesson.
With its multiple formats
like podcasts and games,
in addition to straight up lessons,
Babbel will set you up for
success from the start.
As soon as Wisecrack's finance department
authorizes my very important
research trip to France,
that is not a vacation,
I know I'll be able to rely on Babbel
to help me brush up on my French.
Visit the link in the description
to get 65% off your subscription.
Babel's proven to have you
speak in your new language
in just three weeks and it's backed up
by a 20-day money-back guarantee.
So hit that link in the
description to get 65% off Babbel.
And now back to the show.
Guns are more than a bit
player in American history.
By some historians accounts,
the American Revolution broke
out over anger at Britain
for stopping shipments
of firearms to America
and for confiscating colonists'
limited weapon stockpiles.
I still think the story
about tea is cute though.
The Founding Fathers saw
guns as a useful tool
for hunting and for collective protection.
Owning a gun was mostly mandatory
for a certain subsection of white men,
and some colonies required
them to carry their guns
to church and public meetings.
Imagine getting tooled
up and going to Mass.
Oh, you wouldn't go to Mass
'cause they hated Catholics then.
As tensions between the
colonies and Britain heated up,
guns seemed like the only line of defense
against an oppressive monarch.
Gun culture looked very different, though.
Guns were privately owned,
but they were seen as collective assets,
a shared stockpile to be
used by citizen militias.
And colonial legislation dictated that,
in case of emergency,
the government could
briefly repossess your gun
for use in battle.
Yes, they could literally
come into your house
and take your gun.
(dramatic music)
Another important thing.
The Founding Fathers
didn't only love guns,
they also loved gun control.
Like how, as a white man,
you could only own a gun if
you met certain criteria,
like having a clean criminal record,
swearing loyalty to the union,
or in some places, not being Catholic.
Which if you were to
witness my family reunions,
would make a lot of sense.
Too much booze for guns.
And, of course, Black people
essentially couldn't own guns at all.
And even if you did meet all
the criteria to own a gun,
your use of it was heavily regulated.
You had to register it
with the government,
and there were regular
inspections to make sure
it was ready to be used by the militia.
Certain places had even stricter laws.
In Boston, you couldn't
keep a loaded firearm
inside a building, not even your own home.
Basically, the Founding Fathers
seem to have believed
in gun control measures
that were conducive to public safety.
And wigs. They also
really believed in wigs.
I guess they were self-hating bald men
and thus I don't respect them.
All of this amounted to an early America
that wasn't an especially
violent place to be,
except for the whole war with Britain
and genocide against
Native American stuff.
Not a lot of guns were made here.
And those that were were
handcrafted by gunsmiths
who, like today's task rabbits
typically had to work multiple other gigs
because there wasn't enough
demand for their product.
Shout out to all my "Real Housewives"
and lower tier "Bachelor"
contestants out there.
But in the early 19th century,
the fledgling U.S. army wanted to beef up,
specifically by acquiring uniform guns
with interchangeable parts.
Previously, every gun had been custom made
with custom measurements.
So, industrialists started
inventing the technology
that would make gunsmiths irrelevant,
infrastructure for the mass
production of standardized guns.
Their plan was to score
big government contracts
and make bank.
Selling guns commercially to individuals,
didn't even occur to them.
One key player in this was Samuel Colt,
also known as Dr. Samuel Colt,
a performer known for staging big shows
where he gave people
too much laughing gas.
(audience laughing)
But this guy saw more potential
in the mass manufacturing of guns.
And he went all in, inventing
the revolving cylinder,
which allowed guns to hold
multiple rounds of ammunition,
rendering them significantly more lethal
and definitely not as fun as laughing gas.
Gun makers would continue to come up with
other ways to make their guns more lethal
as a selling point.
But Colt quickly realized he
had two really big problems:
One, the army didn't want
to buy large quantities
of these newfangled guns.
And two, operating at capacity,
his factory could create far
more guns than he could sell.
There just wasn't enough
demand for something that,
at the time, was largely
seen as an instrument of war.
So Colt and his fellow gun manufacturers
had to get creative;
they had to artificially manufacture
a civilian demand for their product.
What a thing to artificially
invent demand for a product.
That's crazy.
I'm glad they stopped doing that.
I'm glad that's never happened since,
that would suck to live in that world.
One company hilariously
patented a cane gun,
which, yes, is a cane that shoots bullets.
Tragically, it wasn't a big hit.
(dramatic percussion music)
For his part, Colt was all about marketing
and heavy discounts.
But, frustrated by
lackluster American demand,
he started thinking internationally.
A war-happy Europe was all
too willing to fill the void.
As historian Pamela Haag puts it,
"It was the European
regimes of the mid-1800s,
"embattled with each other
"and brimming with imperial ambition,
"where the demand for guns ran highest."
Colt began to see the world as his market.
Arming Europe would
embolden those countries
to encroach on Asia, and then, yay,
Asia would need guns, too,
which is very cool and not at
all cynical logic, Mr. Colt.
Dr. Colt.
He traveled abroad bringing lavish gifts
to important statesmen,
and arming anyone who could sign a check.
That included supplying
weapons to Russia and Turkey
in their ongoing war.
It's fun when people killing each other
is good for business.
By the 1880s, nearly all guns
in Europe were made in America
via what was functionally the beginning
of modern globalization.
But back to the 1850s for a sec.
Gun makers still faced a problem.
Gun sales were better during times of war.
But relying on government
contracts meant poor sales
during times of peace.
One of Colt's competitors,
Oliver Winchester had an idea.
What if instead of wedding himself
to American government contracts,
he cultivated a commercial gun market.
Winchester imagined his ideal
customers not to be soldiers,
but to be what Haag
calls citizen-defenders
who would buy guns in defense
of their homes and land.
This is when gun ownership started
being less about the early
logic of collective defense
against an oppressive government,
and more about individual self-defense
against a dangerous frontier.
The struggle to cultivate this
dream market was, for a time,
abated by the Civil War,
which, as you might imagine,
created a huge demand for guns.
And for a man like Colt, it
offered two hungry markets:
the union and the confederacy.
That's right, this ambitious dickbag
armed both sides of the conflict,
causing the New York Times
to accuse him of treason.
But the wars end brought new problems.
Hundreds of thousands of
firearms flooded the markets.
So many former soldiers now owned guns
that the gun market turned abysmal
and gun makers looked back
to international customers.
And they were not discerning.
As scholars Rachel Stohl,
and Suzette Grillot write,
"Manufacturers took advantage
of laissez-faire economics
"and sold weapons to interested customers,
"no matter who or where
they might have been,"
arming despots and dictators alike.
And presumably finally, the Catholics.
American guns spread everywhere from Fiji,
where they replaced boomerangs, to Alaska,
where they armed Inuit people for hunting.
At the time in say, Britain,
gun dealers scrutinize
each customer's character
and integrity.
In America, the vibe was more,
"You get a gun.
"He gets a gun, she gets a gun.
"The dog gets a gun.
"Take this gun for 50% off guns.
So we know by now that
civilians owning guns
is not as American as butter Jesus.
So how did America go from
gun-agnostic to gun-loving?
Advertising. And lots of it.
Marketing historian Robert Henning argues
that advertisements were key to inventing
and shaping American gun culture.
This advertising relied
on the romanticization
of the Wild West,
where the well-armed frontiersman
was literally manifesting
manifest destiny.
Or just literally manifesting destiny.
I don't know.
As legal professor Adam Winkler
notes in his book "Gunfight,"
"Cultural observers have
argued that the frontier
"was not only the root of
the American character,
"but also the origin of America's
propensity for violence."
The Wild West-ification of America
was envisioned through promotional imagery
of Western frontiersmen,
and taglines like:
"God created men.
"Colonel Colt made them equal."
Okay, so now he's Mr. Colt,
Dr. Colt and Colonel Colt.
I don't buy it.
Meanwhile, wildly
popular dime store novels
written on the civilized East Coast
told violent tales of great
gunslingers in the west,
cementing the frontier's legacy.
In this way, guns were
presented in popular media
as the antithesis of proper
East Coast industrial society,
despite the fact that guns
were solely being manufactured
in places like New Haven, Connecticut.
And so the east, mythologizing the west,
began to really arm the country.
Winchester also recognized
the importance of imbuing guns
with a sort of symbolic importance,
anthropomorphizing their
supposed character.
"The great advantage of
this rifle over all others
"consists in the moral
effect it has," he wrote.
I've never read a book of moral philosophy
where someone's like,
"Chapter two, why guns are virtuous?"
Guns were starting to become
a sign of self-sovereignty,
a symbol of American individualism.
So, you might be thinking:
America's idea of violence
came out of the west.
So the west must have
been super violent, right?
Not so fast, cowboy.
The Wild West had tons of guns,
but it also had something in common
with the Founding Fathers,
lots of gun control.
You may picture the Wild
West as one big rowdy,
gun-slinging saloon,
but evidence shows that
murder rates were minimal.
Most people felt so safe they
didn't even lock their doors.
As Winkler notes,
"Almost everyone carried firearms
in the untamed wilderness,
"which was full of dangerous
Natives, outlaws, and bears.
"In the frontier towns, however,
"where people lived and
businesses operated,
"the law often forbade people
"from toting their guns around."
Some of this was strategic.
Frontier towns were
small but wanted to grow,
and to do that, they needed to seem safe.
While lore of western
gunfights mainstreamed guns
and cowboys as twin symbols
of an individualistic America,
the actual west knew
that they couldn't afford
to be as violent as their mythology.
Still, the romanticization of the west
was a highly successful
marketing strategy,
and around the turn of the century,
gun sales were booming.
This is when the gun
really went from serving
as a tool of necessity to
serving a psychological need.
As Haag puts it,
"What was once needed,
now had to be loved."
Which would be a really beautiful quote
if it wasn't describing a gun.
Luckily, it was the perfect time for that.
Historian Kristin Hoganson, among others,
has argued that gender-based
anxieties of the time
engineered a new preoccupation
with a return to manliness
via boxing, football,
war, and of course, guns.
For President Teddy Roosevelt,
the gun was a remedy
against the rapid changes
of modern life, which had
brought about a corporate economy
antithetical to the
individualist American mythos.
Anyway, the mystique of
the gun obscured the fact
that the gun industry was as much a part
of the modern corporate
economy as any other.
When World War I hit,
the gun industry had to step up,
with Winchester securing contracts
to immediately produce the equivalent
of five years worth of orders.
Ironically, this time,
war was a risky
proposition for gun makers.
They had to take out massive loans
to expand their factories to
accommodate all the demand,
and after the war, many
were drowning in debt.
They tried to rebuild via
massive advertising campaigns
that continued into the mid-1900s.
They targeted, among other groups,
women and boys as young as 12
via pamphlets that raved about,
"Four American boys who
are famous rifle shots."
Which is a real advertising slogan
and not something written by a spambot.
Winchester retailers were told to,
"Put a Winchester into the hands
"of every youth in your town,"
with the overall goal of
arming millions of boys
aged 10 to 16, which is
objectively a pretty wild thing
to put on your vision board.
It's crazy that now we're worried about
young people playing video games,
but back then we just gave them guns.
Advertisements stoked fears
that the war had come home,
and danger lurked on every street.
Colt's ads warned that,
"Responsibility for the
protection of your property,
"your home, your loved ones
is too serious a matter
"to be entrusted to an
arm of doubtful lineage."
Guns were touted as totems of masculinity,
protecting men from becoming soft.
Images of wholesome young
red-blooded American men
could assure anyone worried
that America was not,
in fact, "Degenerating into a nation
"of lounge lizard anemics,"
as the Industrial Manufacturer news bureau
delightfully put it.
Also if Lounge Lizard
Anemics isn't a band yet,
someone watching this, start that band.
You know, you'll have good merch.
Advertisements, some modeled
after liquor companies,
were teaching people to
truly love their guns.
Gradually, this sentiment
helped create consumers
who saw guns not as objects of necessity,
but as objects of desire.
And like me buying merch
outside of a Dead show,
these kinds of consumers would buy
way more (beeps) than they needed.
The lore of American gun
culture was persuasive.
By 1959, Winchester could
straight-facedly boast the slogan:
"Winchester: More than a
gun. An American legend."
A legend they had authored themselves,
but okay, sure.
As Haag puts it, "One
answer to the question,
"why do Americans love guns?"
"is, simply, that we were invited to do so
"by those who made and sold them
"at the moment when
their products had shed
"much of their more
practical, utilitarian value."
Still, popular media ran
with Winchester's narrative
offering that, "casual assertions...
"that Americans had always loved guns,
"or that they had a timeless
tradition of gun fluency,"
as Haag writes.
For much of our history,
Americans were actually pretty bad
at actually shooting the guns.
In fact, the NRA was
formed after the Civil War,
specifically because some
veterans were alarmed
at the horrible marksmanship
of Union soldiers.
For much of its history,
the NRA was more about
target-shooting competitions
than influencing politics.
Though today its rhetoric
is fiercely anti-government,
the early NRA relied on major subsidies
to help build gun ranges
and taxpayers even got the privilege
of funding their annual
competition in Ohio.
But then came the 1920s
and '30s, and with it,
prohibition and a huge
spike in urban crime.
And again, with prohibition,
like why is everyone always
trying to keep the Catholics
from doing what they love?
This violence was personified
by the ruthless mobster,
who was typically armed with a Tommy gun,
a highly lethal machine
gun that caused violence
on a scale once unimaginable.
Gun control remained a tough
political sell, though.
By now, gun manufacturers
and America's War Department
had a symbiotic relationship.
The War Department feared that,
if gun businesses couldn't find markets
during times of peace,
they wouldn't be prepared
for times of war.
It's hard to imagine
now, but during this era,
the NRA actually stepped
in and lobbied states
to enact gun control measures.
The sheer magnitude of mob violence
created enough political will in Congress
to pass the National Firearms Act.
The law, and subsequent additions to it,
effectively halted the proliferation
of machine guns permanently.
Retrospectively,
historians view it as proof
that successful gun control
is possible in America.
And then, things were basically
chill on the gun front.
Until this happened.
You may have heard of the Black Panthers,
an activist group that
organized against racism
and police brutality, and
believed that arming Black people
was the best path towards racial justice.
Though they're maybe best
known for carrying guns
and having really good
monochromatic outfits,
they most importantly
provided community resources,
like their free breakfast
program for children.
Leader Huey Newton argued
that the civility of the
Civil Rights Movement
hadn't fixed anything,
and more radical action was necessary.
At one point, this took the
form of 30 armed Black Panthers
legally wielding guns as they protested
at the California State House.
Now's a good moment to talk about the link
between racism and gun culture.
Gun regulation has been used for centuries
to block Black people's access to guns.
In colonial times, enslaved people
and even free blacks
weren't allowed to own guns,
because colonists feared
they'd use them to rise up.
Hell, the KKK began as a
gun control organization.
No. Seriously.
It formed after the Civil War
to confiscate guns from Black
men, including veterans.
Guns became an important
means of protection
for freed Southern Black
people to fight violent racism,
with some Black men forming
militias to stop lynchings.
A century later, the Black
Panthers similarly decided
that carrying guns for self-defense
was the only way they could
gain respect and safety.
And that really freaked white people out.
In fact, the Panthers
so alarmed lawmakers,
that they helped inspire
the strictest national gun
regulation America had ever seen:
the Gun Control Act of 1968,
along with the Omnibus Crime
Control and Safe Streets Act.
These laws were also inspired
in part by collective grief
over a series of political assassinations,
including MLK, JFK, and Robert Kennedy.
The laws expanded federal
licensing for guns,
and they forbade ex-felons,
people with certain mental illnesses,
illegal drug users, and
children from owning guns.
And it restricted imports
of so-called Saturday Night Special guns,
which were frequently used in crime
and different from
"Saturday Night Fever" guns,
which were real sparkly
and played disco music when you shot them.
Note that the NRA supported
some of these measures
and even reluctantly endorsed the law.
And yet, even as political
will favored gun control,
the gun industry still received
some special protection
from higher-ups.
It was the sole industry
to be exempt from oversight
via the new Consumer
Product Safety Commission
created in 1972.
According to The Trace,
this is because house
representatives feared
a slippery slope that
would lead the agency
to confiscate people's guns.
This functionally means that
there's more federal oversight
over a toy gun than a real one,
which is too depressing to be funny.
Seriously, it means that the
government has more oversight
over this plastic piece of crap than a gun
that shoots bullets.
I don't know. Oh, (beeps)!
It also has real consequences.
Plenty have pointed out
that gun manufacturers
could make guns safer,
by fixing flaws in trigger
locks or personalizing guns
so they can only be used by their owner.
But without federal oversight,
there's no incentive for
the industry to make sure
all guns sold meet
minimum safety standards.
But back to 1968.
The gun control measures that
did make it through Congress
would have a complicated legacy.
As Winkler notes,
"If it hadn't been for
the Black Panthers...
"there might never have been
a modern gun rights movement."
That's because, he explains,
these new strict laws,
which were, "aimed largely at disarming
"urban black leftist radicals,
"led to a backlash by
rural white conservatives."
Now, you may be wondering
why we haven't mentioned one
of the essential talking points
of the gun rights debate in America.
The second amendment, which reads:
"A well regulated militia,
"being necessary to for the
security of a free state,
"the right of the people
to keep and bear arms,
"shall not be infringed."
There's a good reason it
hasn't come up, though.
Until the 1960s, the second amendment
wasn't one of the popular kids.
It didn't play into the gun debate,
and was generally ignored
by legal scholars.
The Supreme Court did use
it to uphold challenges
to the 1934 law,
arguing that sawed-off
shotguns and machine guns
wouldn't be used by a state militia,
and thus could be regulated.
This was the militia
interpretation of the amendment;
that it only protected gun rights insofar
as they would apply to
arming a citizen militia.
But scholars in the '60s
and '70s started arguing
for a more individual interpretation
of the second amendment.
And the NRA went HAM
on this interpretation,
even bolting an excerpt of the amendment
to the outside of their headquarters.
Eventually, the individual interpretation
would be borne out in a
Supreme Court decision
on District of Columbia
vs. Heller in 2008,
which overturned D.C.'s ban on handguns
in a hotly controversial decision.
The question of the individual
vs. militia interpretation
remains contested by scholars.
For his part, back in 1991,
former Chief Justice Warren Burger
called the individual interpretation
of the second amendment-
- One of the greatest pieces of fraud,
I repeat the word fraud
on the American public
by special interest groups
that I have ever seen in my lifetime.
- We're not gonna go too
deep on the second amendment,
and not just because the
debate is pretty boring.
The thing is, we actually don't think
this clause of the Constitution
is as essential to the gun debate
as it's been made out to be.
Because let's say you do take
the strongest individualist
interpretation of the amendment,
holding that the Founding Fathers
believed in the protected
individual right to own a gun.
Well, the Founding Fathers, as you know,
also believed in lots of gun control,
so clearly they felt that this
right could be infringed on
if it meant protecting public safety.
That is to say, you can both believe
in the individualist
interpretation of the amendment
and believe that gun control
measures are necessary.
Because you, yes you, contain multitudes.
But back to the '70s.
Now armed with revelatory
constitutional backup,
the NRA leapt into the decade,
establishing an official lobbying wing,
where both the NRA and cocaine,
the '70s were a hell of a decade.
Ironically, though mostly white,
the group borrowed a lot of
the Black Panthers' arguments
that guns were necessary for self-defense,
not only in the home but on the street,
where bumbling cops surely
couldn't be relied upon.
There was some lingering tension, though,
between the old guards
who had cooperated on gun control laws,
and newer, more radical members
who believed any form of gun control
was a slippery slope to
having their gun room
raided by communists.
The anti-gun control
extremists staged a coup
at the NRA's national meeting in '77,
setting the NRA on a more aggressive path.
At the same time,
a decision by the Supreme Court
allowed for unfettered political spending.
The NRA refocused on campaign
donations and fundraising,
funneling millions into local,
state and national elections.
In the process, they gained
some serious lobbying power.
Not that much gun control
was liable to happen
under the winner of the NRA's
first presidential
endorsement, Ronald Reagan.
Energized by Reagan's win,
the NRA pushed legislation that
protected the gun industry.
That included the Firearm
Owners Protection Act,
which restricted
inspections of gun dealers,
loosened the rules on
interstate gun sales,
and made a federal database
of gun ownership illegal.
Speaking off the record,
some politicians admitted that
they only voted for the law
because they were intimidated
by the NRA's power.
What a system of government we have.
Other big wins included
making it extremely difficult
to sue gun manufacturers,
removing law enforcement's
power to use discretion
when issuing concealed carry licenses,
and preventing local governments
from regulating firearms.
But as the '80s wore on, NRA
membership started declining.
Once again, it would take the threat
of new federal gun control
to bring the organization back to life.
Jim Brady was serving as
White House Press Secretary
when he was shot, and partially paralyzed,
during an assassination
attempt on Reagan in 1981.
His attacker, coincidentally,
was just released from prison
and now has a sizable
social media following
because we live in a weird world.
Brady and his wife became
gun control activists,
and in 1988, they
introduced the Brady Bill,
requiring background
checks on all handguns
sold by licensed dealers.
It finally passed in 1993,
followed by an assault
weapons ban in 1994,
both of which inflamed the NRA.
As the Washington Post
explains in its book,
"Guns in America,"
NRA rhetoric got gnarlier and gnarlier.
In a fundraising letter,
President Wayne LaPierre wrote
that the assault weapons ban,
"Gives jackbooted government thugs
"more power to take away
our constitutional rights,
"break in our doors,
"seize our guns,
"destroy our property and
even injure and kill us."
When one-time NRA member Timothy McVeigh
blew up the Alfred P.
Murrah Federal Building
in Oklahoma City in April of 1995,
the NRA was criticized for
its anti-government rhetoric,
which some thought
encouraged the militant.
Why ever would they think that?
The organization tried
to improve its image
under the presidency of
famous actor Charleton Heston
through great PR move
like holding its national
convention in Denver
two weeks after Columbine.
Surely a mistake they'd never make again.
Except for when they did the
exact same thing in Houston
three days after the Uvalde shooting.
Great job, NRA, really good planning.
More strategically, the
group allied heavily
with George W. Bush's campaign in 2000,
leading to this delicious bit of PR.
- For everyone within
the sound of my voice
to hear and to heed,
and especially for you, Mr. Gore.
(audience laughing)
From my cold dead hands!
- Citing Bush's eventual victory,
Fortune magazine ranked the NRA
the most powerful lobbying
organization in the country.
But the aughts brought
victory after victory.
The assault rifle ban expired in 2004,
and in 2008 the Supreme Court knocked down
the D.C. handgun ban.
Ironically, the NRA may
have lobbied its way
out of relevancy.
The organization is strongest
when people feel their gun
rights are under attack.
The organization would
eventually lose steam
in the late 2010s, thanks to lawsuits,
leadership scandals, a bankruptcy
filing that was rejected,
and overall declining membership.
Their political donations
have proportionately dwindled down,
although they still managed to spend
over $29 million dollars in
the 2020 federal elections.
With the NRA dying a slow
death, it's worth asking,
what does that mean for gun culture?
Honestly, not a whole lot.
Gun rights continues to be a winning issue
for Republicans courting primary voters.
Lawmakers might no longer
fear retaliation from the NRA,
but they do fear looking like
they're trying to take away people's guns.
Meanwhile, gun sales have
nearly tripled since 2000,
spiking especially over
the past three years.
Presumably, so people could
shoot the novel coronavirus
and not get sick.
We live in violent times,
with American gun deaths up 34% from 2019.
And that's a 49% increase
over the previous five years.
In the last 10 years,
that figure's risen 75%.
With faith in law
enforcement generally down,
it's no wonder that people
are looking to arm themselves,
or increase their stockpile.
And that idea brings us back
to the issue of self-defense,
which has been sold as the
central reason to buy a gun
since the mid-19th century,
and has only become a
more compelling reason
in recent years.
(machine gun firing)
(woman screaming)
- [Woman] Hunny, can
you bring mommy the mop?
- Now, wanting a gun to protect yourself
in a country that's
swimming in them is fair.
But if you think owning a gun makes you,
pardon the expression, bulletproof,
the data really doesn't bear that out.
Estimates of the number of
defensive gun uses range from
100,000 to over 2 million per year,
depending on methodologies, sample size,
and the definition of defensive gun use.
Given discrepancies in data,
criminologist Thomas Gabor recommends
looking at police officers
as a reference point,
since they are armed,
trained to wield guns,
and not infrequently encounter danger.
According to James Fyfe, an
expert on police gun use,
a big-city cop is involved in a shootout
every 450 years, on average.
Again, that's every 450 years, on average.
Almost half of a thousand years.
Another calculation found
that in any given year,
only one in 170 cops is
involved in a shooting.
As Gabor concludes,
"These numbers show that
even police officers,
"who are armed and are
more routinely involved
"in dangerous situations
than the average citizen,
"rarely rely on guns
when doing police work."
Unless their talking to a
harmless, young Black person,
then they definitely need guns.
No, that's not gonna go in
the video, but it's true.
This raises the question,
why would people doing
far less dangerous jobs
need to be armed all the time?
But there's a much deeper problem
with the self-defense argument.
Research from the Centers of
Disease Control and Prevention
found that more than
three-quarters of homicide victims
knew their attacker.
Because of this, bringing
a gun into the home
actually poses more of a
threat to the residents
than it poses defense against intruders.
Sort of like, if you bring
36 beers into your house,
you're more likely to
get drunk from the beers
than if you didn't bring
the beers into your house.
Was that a scientific comparison? No.
But if you bring 36 beers into your house,
what do you thinks gonna happen?
This is particularly true for women,
who are two to four times more likely
to be intentionally killed by a gun
if they live in a house with one.
If the person you're most afraid of
is the person sharing your bed,
putting a gun under your pillow
isn't exactly a setup for safety.
As Harvard professor
and public health expert
David Hemenway summarizes,
"Scientific studies suggest
"that the health risk of a gun in the home
"is greater than the benefit,"
and that, "a gun in the home
"may more likely be used
to threaten intimates
"than to protect against intruders."
Add to that the increased
likelihood of homicide,
suicide and accidental deaths
occurring in houses with guns,
and it becomes an even
more dangerous prospect.
By the way, we've linked
two domestic abuse
and suicide support
lines in the description.
This all suggests that, on a micro level,
the mere presence of guns
increases the likelihood
of multiple forms of violence.
This has been borne
out in other countries.
For example, when Israel
stopped letting soldiers
bring their guns home on weekends,
soldier suicides decreased
by a staggering 40%.
This all suggests that having guns around
simply makes violence more likely.
Again, if you're in a bar,
you're more likely to get drunk.
If you're in a bathroom,
you're more likely to...
go to the bathroom.
The failure of guns to deter crime
are clear on a regional level as well.
In 2014, the South was the
region with the highest rate
of violent and property crimes;
the Northeast had the lowest.
42% of households in the South had a gun,
compared to 25% of
houses in the Northeast.
As Gabor concludes, "These
regional comparisons
"provide no support for the idea
"that higher gun ownership levels
"serve as a net deterrent to crime."
Now, there's an obvious reason gun sales
tend to go up after a mass shooting.
People want to be prepared.
Although they account for
approximately one-half
of 1% of gun violence in the country,
mass shootings garner the most headlines
and political attention.
And this makes sense.
Though we're more likely to be killed
by a family member or a
friend than by a stranger,
mass shootings remind us
that we can't simply avoid gun violence
just by being nice to our mom,
or picking the right friends.
The first modern mass shooting
as defined by journalist Seamus McGraw,
who I would bet my life is
a Catholic occurred in 1966,
when a man opened fire
from a tower in Texas
and killed 17 people.
And so, the romanticized image
of the lone American gunman
protecting himself from bears
mutated into the lone
gunman turning his weapon
on innocent civilians with
no clear motive or agenda.
Over the coming decades, the mass shooter,
typically young, white, and male,
would become a collective
boogeyman in the American psyche.
- [Reporter] Tonight
authorities say they've arrested
the alleged gunman,
identified as an 18-year-old white male
from Conklin, New York.
- In response to recent mass shootings,
including the one at Uvalde Elementary,
there have been calls to arm teachers.
We should be skeptical of the idea
that a good guy with a gun
could offer much protection
in the event of a mass shooting.
First of all, not even
cops, who are trained,
hit their target the majority of the time.
Indeed, inspector Kevin
Maloney of the NYPD
reported that in 2017,
city cops hit their target
just 44% of the time.
Also, if there was a
platonic name for NYPD cop
it would be Kevin Maloney.
Logically, you would
have to expect a teacher
to underperform a cop.
And, in a crowded public space,
missing your mark can
mean killing someone else.
Secondly, having multiple
people firing guns
at a crime scene is a recipe
for police confusion and chaos.
Police learn this at
the Texas Tower in 1966,
when several onlookers started
firing back at the shooter,
stoking even more panic.
Journalist Seamus McGraw
writes in his book
"From a Taller Tower," that,
"As John McDonald, executive
director of security
"at Jefferson County Public
Schools told the Denver Post,
"in such situations, adding
another gun to the mix
"can have tragic consequences."
Thirdly, modern firearms
have become so lethal
that a bystander can't really
prevent profound loss of life.
In one example in Ohio,
the police responded within seconds,
but not quickly enough to stop the shooter
from killing nine people
and wounding 27 more.
Even if Jason Bourne was your teacher,
even he likely couldn't respond in time.
Given these facts,
the results of FBI studies of
277 active-shooter scenarios
make sense.
They found that only 3.9% concluded
with a good guy with a gun firing a shot.
Meanwhile, 11% were stopped
by unarmed civilians.
Again, that means, that unarmed
civilians have done more
to stop mass shootings
than good guys with guns.
What's more, if we want
to know what happens
when you have more good guys
with guns in their pockets,
we can simply look to some
Latin American countries
where guns are basically ubiquitous,
yet certainly have not
made communities safer.
Rather, well-armed
countries like Guatemala,
Honduras, and El Savador
have some of the world's
highest homicide rates.
As Rebecca Peters,
former director of the
International Action Network
on Small Arms, argues,
"A society that is
relying on guys with guns
"to stop violence is a sign of a society
"where institutions have broken down.
"It's shocking to hear
anyone in the United States
"considering a solution
"that would make it seem
more like Colombia."
Also worth noting,
many of those countries have guns
because Reagan shipped them
down there in the '80s.
You just Google that.
It's all real. I swear to God.
In contrast though, Switzerland
has a high rate of gun ownership,
but a very low rate of gun homicides,
in part because guns are mostly seen
as official military weapons,
rather than tools for self-defense.
Switzerland brings us
to a separate question.
Why is America so uniquely violent
compared to other wealthy nations?
There's a lot of factors,
but you probably won't be surprised
that other countries are
worried that American violence
might be contagious.
As then Prime Minister John Howard said
after Australia's Port
Arthur Massacre in 1996,
"We do not want the American disease
"imported into Australia."
Unlike in America, mass
shootings in comparable countries
have been followed by
sweeping gun control action.
And while it's almost
impossible to imagine America
taking action to meaningfully
curb gun violence,
at least with all the
partisan gridlock in play,
many other countries have pulled it off.
After the previously mentioned massacre,
Australia swiftly rolled out
stringent gun ownership
requirements and restrictions,
along with a huge gun buyback program.
After a school shooting
in the UK, also in 1996,
Parliament rolled out a
similarly strict set of laws,
and there hasn't been a school
shooting in the UK since.
In other words, The Onion got us again.
Which makes it all the more depressing
that American gun violence
continues unabated.
73% of mass shootings in
industrialized countries
have occurred in ye olde United States,
even though we make up
just 5% of the population.
As of early June,
there had been more
than 250 mass shootings
in the U.S. this year alone.
Where does this uniquely
American violence come from?
According to McGraw,
some of it is the result
of a media culture
that valorizes fame.
He writes, "That thirst for
fame runs deep in our culture,
"and it can make people
do terrible things."
Now obviously America is very
much a fame-obsessed society,
but there are plenty
of aspiring celebrities
all over the world and you
don't hear about Scottish goths
shooting up schools for the clout.
So that still doesn't explain
what makes mass shootings
so damn American.
Some of it's rooted in good
old-fashioned prejudice.
Frequently, mass shooters
are taking their anger out
on an identity group, whether
another race, as in Buffalo;
religion, as in the
Tree of Life synagogue;
or women, as in Isla Vista, California.
But in recent years, there's
been a chilling development
of mass shooters streaming their violence,
and going viral in the dark
crevices of the internet.
This strengthens the idea
that they're searching for
some sort of twisted glory.
Maybe in their heads they
are the lone American gunman
romanticized throughout our culture.
Indeed, McGraw notes that
certain types of guns
take on a fetishistic element
amongst mass shooters;
a sort of twisted extension
of our national love of guns.
When a mass shooting happens,
there's an instant rush
to figure out the cause of
such senseless violence.
And there's inevitably talk
about the mental illness
crisis in America,
which, while being a very real problem,
is a bit of a misdirection.
Stats suggest that up
to 61% of mass shooters
have some form of mental illness.
And certainly, if America
had better resources
for mental health care,
maybe those shooters
could have been treated
before resorting to violence.
But what about the other 40%?
While certainly not in a great headspace,
given the whole mass shooting thing,
these people aren't
explicitly mentally ill.
Rather, they often exhibit
signs of narcissism,
with a deep sense of
grievance against the world.
But we can't just go
arresting all the narcissists
on the off chance that
they can go postal, can we?
Wait, can we?
'Cause I have a list of
some narcissists in my life
that I would love to give the authorities.
What's more, some 80% of
guns used in mass shootings
were purchased legally,
so it's not like better
enforcement of existing laws
could have stopped them.
There is one thing
most mass shooters have in common, though,
domestic violence.
Over two-thirds of mass shooters
either killed family or intimate partners,
or were involved in
domestic violence disputes.
On a larger scale,
the overlap of domestic
violence and mass shootings
suggests that, rather than
being some kind of fluke
or outlier, they are an extension
of the broader structures
of everyday American violence.
Much of which is predicated
on the extreme lethality of modern guns.
So is there something embedded in the DNA
of America's history that just makes us
more prone to shoot people?
We're not sure.
But it does seem like a series of factors
ranging from America's colonial past,
to western expansion,
to an economy built on war,
to an emphasis on individual
liberty above all else,
to underfunded mental health care,
to the way domestic violence is ignored
until it becomes lethal.
Yeah, that's a lot of stuff!
There's a lot of things.
Oh, it's very overwhelming.
These things have all
coalesced in the modern era
to make America #1 in mass shootings
and other gun-related deaths.
And because it's not just
one, or two, or three things
at the root of this problem,
it sadly seems like there's no easy fix.
But hey, you can use an online dating app,
meet and marry a Swiss national
and then you can live in a country
where you can own a gun and
eat unlimited Toblerones
without worrying about mass shootings.
But what do you guys think?
Is there something inherently
violent about America?
Can our gun violence
problem ever be fixed?
If you know, please let
us know in the comments.
And don't forget that
we've linked to resources
for domestic abuse and suicide prevention
in the description.
We've also included a reading
list in the description
if you're interested in learning more.
Now smash that subscribe button
like a Satanist destroying butter Jesus,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
A huge thanks to our patrons
for all your support.
Be sure to check out our
revamped Patreon page.
Remember to check out our
new stream Wisecrack Live
that takes place every
Thursday right on this channel.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)
That makes no sense to me, I guess.
Were boomerangs like murder weapons?
There was blade boomerangs.
(tense dramatic music)